Pog
Not Pog
Pogu
so
Jetzt bin ich am Start
Moin Leute
Michael 5 Trillionen auch wieder da
Hyper Pog
Moment gibt das das Emote? Das hat doch bestimmt schon irgendjemand der her natürlich
Was sonst war, war klar. Ja wir machen heute 1-2 Aufgaben von den Neuen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Mein Brain ausreicht, mich da heute noch groß zu konzentrieren, das werden wir wissen
Spätestens nach der ersten Aufgabe
Und dann machen wir weiter oder nicht, muss man mal gucken
Sonst guckt man noch irgendwie ein bisschen YouTube Schwachsinn und dann
Uma müde, Buma im Bett, gell
Wie sehr irgendwie scheiße das ist, wenn man auf dem Fahrrad umgefahren wird. Nicht so sehr, weil man umgefahren wird, sondern
Weil es wahrscheinlich ewig dauert, bis die Versicherung was bezahlt
Und man nicht weiß, ob man sich jetzt neues Fahrrad bestellen kann oder das alte noch repariert werden soll
Ist richtig, richtig dämlich, Alter, wenn sich das ausgedacht hat, man
Du hast eigentlich, du bist eigentlich als Umgefahrener doppelt am Arsch
Prosti, gr, dankeschön für den Sub
Richtig dämlich, man
Ja, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich nirgendwo
Oder gar nicht, bei nichts, ja, das ist halt voll für den Arsch
Also, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl, entweder ich warte, ist richtig, richtig weird, Champ
Entweder ich warte halt jetzt irgendwie ein paar Monate, bis ich mir ein neues Fahrrad kaufe, ob ich weiß, ob ich halt ein neues
Ersetzt kriege oder das alte repariert wird, ich gehe nicht davon aus, aber man weiß es ja nicht
Oder ich kaufe mir auf gut Glück ein neues
Und dann sagen sie, das alte wird doch repariert, das ist so kacke, Alter
Richtige Penner, alles, man, so dumm
Richtig dumm, naja, zumindest, das Gute ist, habe ich auch gerade gesagt, es ist kaputt
Also, was heißt kaputt, es hat halt verbogen das Rad, ich war beim Gutachter, der hat sich das angeguckt, hat gesagt, hier
Carbonrahmen, voll für den Arsch und
Ja, jetzt muss er mal gucken, was das kostet, wenn man das ersetzen würde und
Wahrscheinlich läuft es darauf raus, dass es neu ist, ja, ja, niemand nimmt dir den Carbonrahmen ab
Der hat Kratzer und hat Schläge abbekommen, niemand nimmt dir den Rahmen ab und sagt, es passt
Rückgaberecht für was?
Nach Wohnfall, ja, ist klar
Welchen Bürostuhl hast du? Ich glaube, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Stuhl im Chat, ich glaube, wir haben sogar
einen Link zu meinem Stuhl irgendwo
Probier mal, oder, warte mal, ich probier das mal, Ausrufezeichen Stuhl, ja, geht doch, hier, guck, den habe ich
Das Ding hier
Dreht er sich, ja
Besser, POG, POG Chair, das ist der Original POG Chair
Das hört sich falsch an, warum?
Was ist passiert?
Ich bin auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren, Leute, ich mach schon mal kurz die Vm an, weil die Vm, wobei, brauchen wir die Vm überhaupt?
Ja, doch, die Vm brauchen wir, eigentlich brauchen wir die Vm nicht, aber wir brauchen die Vm
Ja, Vm wäre jetzt nicht
Was ist passiert? Also, ich bin auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren
So wie man das ja eigentlich nicht, wie soll ich sagen,
Nicht besser machen kann als Fahrradfahrer, also besser als auf der Straße, ich bin auf dem Fahrradweg gefahren
Und da gab es halt Ausfahrt
Wobei das nicht wirklich eine Ausfahrt war, das war so ein, so ein, ja doch, eine Ausfahrt, Ausfahrt trifft es, glaube ich, ganz gut
Aber, du hast komplett Vorfahrt auf dem Fahrradweg
Und das siehst du auch, wenn man auf Google Maps guckt, dass die bei der Ausfahrt komplett Vorfahrt achten haben
Inklusive Anzeige noch mal, dass ein Fahrradweg ist, durchgestrichelte Linie um Fahrradweg
Und ich bin halt da vorbeigefahren und bei der Ausfahrt ist einer rausgefahren, hat mich von der Seite umgefahren
Und mir ist glücklicherweise nicht allzu viel passiert
Ich war, ich war aber noch mal beim Doktor und hab das
Zumindest, zumindest aufnehmen lassen alles
also
Also ich, ich hab, ich hab nicht wirklich körperlich großartig was, ja
Wir haben die ersten paar Tage, es war am Samstag
Wir haben die ersten paar Tage halt nur ein bisschen, ein bisschen noch das Bein weh getan und der Arm auf der einen Seite, ein bisschen
der Hüfte hier auf der rechten Seite, merke ich es auch noch
Ein bisschen der Rücken und so, aber das ging, das ist jetzt eigentlich fast alles schon wieder weg
Das dumme ist halt, dass das Fahrrad im Arsch ist, beziehungsweise das Fahrrad ist nicht richtig im Arsch
Eigentlich, denke ich, wenn man das Vorderrad, also doch, es ist, es ist auf jeden Fall im Arsch, also
Ich war ja, ich war ja beim Gutachter und da hat er noch, der hat noch
noch jede Menge neues Zeug gefunden
Jetzt ist bloß die große Preisfrage, ob sich reparieren lohnt oder nicht
Wahrscheinlich lohnt sich nicht, weil sie den Rahmen eh austauschen müssen, aber es ist halt für den Arsch, ja
Ich muss jetzt ewig warten, bis die, bis die ihren Kram da geschissen bekommen haben bei der Versicherung, bis ich dann das Geld bekomme
Weil ansonsten, ich kann mir halt nicht auf gut Glück ein neues Fahrrad kaufen, wenn ich auf gut Glück ein neues Fahrrad kaufe
Und denen fällt dann doch ein, ach hier, ja, lass mal lieber reparieren, dann habe ich zwei
So und das, das einzige, das einzige, was ich jetzt machen kann, ist, ich kann es auf, auf so einen Smart Trainer daheim stellen
Da habe ich mir vor ein paar Tagen noch einen gekauft, noch bevor ich den, bevor ich den Unfall hatte, witzigerweise, hat sich ganz gut ergeben
Ich kann es jetzt halt nur noch daheim verwenden
Ich habe das Ding vorhin aufgebaut
Morgen mache ich mal das Fahrrad drauf
Ist ja nicht so groß, morgen mache ich mal das Fahrrad drauf und guck mal
Ob man nicht auch im Wohnzimmer gescheit fahren kann, ja, einen Wahoo, Wahoo Kikr, ein richtig dummer Name, alter, Kikr
Das ist, da kommst du dir ja vor, wie in Zeiten, als das angesagt war, Twitter hieß ja am Anfang auch Twittr
Und, und, und da gab es Flickr und so, das war eine Zeit lang voll angesagt, dass sich, dass sich die, die, so Dienste
Krrrrrrrrrrr hinten nennen
Aber gut, das Ding macht ganz guten Eindruck, war auf jeden Fall super easy aufzubauen
Benutzt du, Pogrrrrr
Das finde ich auch gut, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es das nicht sogar gäbe irgendwo, wenn ich mal kurz, Pogrrr, such ich jetzt nicht öfter, man weiß ja nie, wo man da
Benutzt du irgendwelche Cycling-Apps oder so
Es gibt ja, es gibt ja so ein paar Multiplayer-Apps sogar, wo man mit anderen Leuten da irgendwie rumfahren kann
Es wird, ja na gut, das, das hat glaube ich Gefühl jeder, ja das werde ich auch mal ausprobieren, aber es sagt halt einfach mal richtig
Also war der Verursacher einsüchtig, ja, die war übelst fertig, die war glaube ich noch fertiger als ich
Ich, ich bin der gar nicht so großartig böse, ja
Was mich halt abfuckt, ist, dass sich das jetzt so ewig lang wahrscheinlich hinzieht
Aber das einzig Richtige war tatsächlich jetzt auch, das habe ich mir
fast schon im Stream am Sonntag dann überlegt, oder Samstag, weiß ich nicht, ja doch Sonntag, Sonntag, dass ich, dass ich mir jetzt einen Anwalt suche
dass ich mich nicht um den ganzen Kram kümmern muss und mir nichts verpassen, habe ich auch gemacht, ich habe mir einen Anwalt rausgesucht
und der kümmert sich jetzt darum, der hat da auch schon was hingeschickt
und ich war beim Gutachter gestern, vorgestern, nee gestern, ich war beim Gutachter und der hat von allem Fotos gemacht
und meint halt, es dauert immer ein bisschen, weil er muss jetzt erstmal online anfragen, was die Preise sind für die Teile und so
ist halt, äh, Autounfall, naja, wie man es nimmt, Unfall mit einem Auto, ja das stimmt, da bin ich aber auf dem Fahrrad gesessen
Ja, ja, gehe ich auch von aus, das heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht trotzdem repariert wird, es könnte ja auch sein, dass jemand sagt, aha, der Rahmen kostet neu, keine Ahnung, 1500 Euro
und dann rechnet sich das ja, wenn man das reparieren lässt, so, es ist halt für, also es ist ziemlich viel im Arsch, ja, der Rahmen ist im Arsch, der Lenker hat ein Schlagwerk
da ist sogar der Sattel, sogar das Pedal, ähm, das habe ich alles gar nicht so, gar nicht auf den ersten Blick selbst gesehen, ähm, sogar die Schaltung ist verbogen
Bezahlst du den Anwalt selber? Naja, ich hoffe mal, dass die Sache so klar ist, dass der von der Versicherung bezahlt wird dann, aber eventuell muss ich es vielleicht selber erstmal bezahlen
Aber die Sache ist, also aus meiner Sicht ist die wirklich übelst, übelst klar, komplett vorfahrend und von der Seite umgefahren worden, also, was willst du noch machen?
Was macht eigentlich der Tesla Truck? Gibt's den mittlerweile? Es gibt eine GTA 5 Mod für Smart Trainer, ja das ist nice, kann man dann, kann man dann Fahrrad fahren in der Stadt oder wie?
Eigentlich ist das eine ziemlich coole Sache, schwer zu sagen, ich würde sagen, ungefähr so alt wie ich, vielleicht ein bisschen älter, also so 45 oder so, hätte ich jetzt vielleicht mal gesagt
Ja, das mache ich ja eh, unabhängig, unabhängig vom Fahrradfahren, das mache ich ja eh, wobei ich jetzt schon, ich war jetzt bestimmt fast, fast ne, naja nicht ganz, aber fast ne Woche nicht mehr rennen
Das lag aber auch unter anderem daran, weil ich eigentlich vorhatte, okay, fährst Samstag fährst du Fahrrad, musst nicht unbedingt alles am gleichen Tag machen und nach dem Unfall hat mir dann halt erstmal das Bein wehgetan, da wollte ich nicht rennen
Also wahrscheinlich gehe ich morgen früh wieder, ist jetzt eigentlich alles soweit gut, ja das war wahrscheinlich das Problem, dass ich auf dem Fahrrad, also ich suche mir ja immer, wenn ich die Routen plane, sei es jetzt bei Komoot oder mit Bike Router oder so, übrigens, wer das nicht kennt, kann man echt empfehlen, Moment, ist das das Richtige überhaupt?
Weiß nicht, ähm, sieht irgendwie komisch aus, ja, aber das Ding, das Ding ist wirklich mega nice zum, zum Planen von Routen, man kann es natürlich, man, nein, nein, man kann es natürlich auch über Komoot oder so machen, das mache ich auch für Navigation am Ende dann, wobei ich das auch über den Fahrradcomputer machen kann, je nachdem, aber das, das ist wirklich mega, mega nice, vor allem hier die, die, ähm, Profile, die man auswählen kann, die, die man auswählen kann, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die,
die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die
hat der Log-Shipper ein Problem, der crasht immer und
dem, der Log-Shipper darf nicht auf dem, auf den Logger
nee
Was?
Der Log-Shipper hat ein Problem
und es ist ihm verboten zu sehen, was der Logger
Was? Ich gehe davon aus, die möchten mir sagen, dass der Log-Shipper nicht auf den Logger richtig zugreifen kann oder umgedreht
Could you help fix Log-Shipper
Okay, also wir sollen den Log-Shipper reparieren
Wir können die Status von den Pods abfragen mit kubectl get pods. Okay, seriously, ich glaube
Wenn das die einzige Hilfe ist, die man für Kubanetes bekommt
Das hätte man auch gewusst, wenn man den Rest lösen kann, gehe ich mal von aus
so und dann
Wir sollen nicht das Kubanetes-Yaml-Zeug ändern für den Log-Shipper-Pod
Und wir sollen sudo machen, wenn wir uns einloggen, so interpretiere ich das mal
So und am Ende sollen wir checken, dass das, okay, dass das running ist, alles klar
Oh shit, man
Will ich mir das jetzt echt geben? Das ist entweder easy oder abfuck. Ich weiß es jetzt schon
Ey, wir machen das jetzt, bam
Kubaneten-Stills
Die Frage ist ja immer noch, ist es Kubanetes, Kubanetes, Kubanetes, Kubanetes, Kubanetes
Cates, wie das manche nennen, was ich übelst dämlich finde, Alter. Kennt ihr Leute, die Kubanetes Cates nennen?
Also nicht ausgeschrieben K8S, das mache ich auch. Es gibt Leute, die sagen ernsthaft Cates, das hört sich an wie Aids
Also richtig bescheuert
Welches OS ist das? Arch Linux, by the way, use ich, guck
Du solltest auch Arch Linux nutzen, weil Arch Linux die einzig wahre Linux-Distribution ist
Aber mit Arch Linux alleine wird es nicht viel weiterkommen, muss es erstmal so einrichten. Also das ist i3
Also i3-WM
Und falls du genau wissen willst, wie die Configs aussehen, dann findest du das hier auf
ShitHub
Ist der Server da? Ja, okay, auf geht's
Oh man, wie gesagt, ich weiß jetzt schon, es wird entweder, wie viel Zeit haben wir eigentlich? 20 Minuten, okay, okay, 20 Minuten
20 Minuten
Ich weiß jetzt schon, es wird entweder easy oder abfang, okay, kubectl get
Oh ne, wir haben noch nicht mal autocomplete für, oh, fuck
Ist kaputt, okay, pass mal auf, check my solution, äh, was?
Wait a minute
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, jetzt weiß ich nicht so genau, was los ist
Easy? Fragezeichen, easy?
Your score is the best one so far
Geil, nice, wir sind, wir sind top one leaderboard
Das scheit nicht so ganz
Ranking? Lass mal gucken, wo sind wir, wo sind wir, wo sind wir im Ranking? Also hier, packs, irgendwas, Ranking, ah ne, war ich drüber
Welches haben wir gerade gemacht?
Buenos Aires, 31 Sekunden best time
Wie, das steht nicht von wem?
Wir haben die bestzeit, 31 Sekunden
Ich vermute, da ist irgendwas kaputt
Seriously, irgendwas ist da kaputt, weil es sollte nicht einfach einloggen und es geht
Ich würde sagen, wir machen das noch mal und gucken uns das in Ruhe an
Weil das, das wird's, das wird's nicht gewesen sein, ne?
Oh, sehr gute Idee, sehr gute Idee, Splixer
Ja, ja, ja, ja, sehr gute Idee, muss man das, muss man das irgendwie
sourcen oder irgendwie in eine Datei schreiben oder
Ich glaube, das kann man, ich glaube, das kann man sich in die Becher-C hauen mit einem Source, ge? Irgendwie so
Ich habe das vor drei, 30
Jahren oder so mal in meine Becher-C eingetragen, lass mal kurz gucken, wo bloß
Cube CTL
Ja, Leute, ich gucke einfach aus meinen Dot-Files ab, dann ist das, ist das ja eigentlich kein Beschiss, so
Na auf, Sliepke, Bettke, AWS macht Bettke gerade
Ah ja, da sind wir, okay
Alles klar
Ach so, Moment, Cube CTL get Pots, ging ja gar nicht, also Sudo soll ich usen, okay
Cube CTL, nope, get Pots minus A
Jetzt ist er auf Error, okay
Das ist bestimmt ein Bug, Leute, kann das sein, dass es irgendwie
Wenn du, wenn du zu schnell auf Check Solution klickst, dass der Pod noch keine Chance hatte zu failen
Irgendwie sowas, das können wir
Das können wir Set Servers auf Twitter posten, ist gut, dass ihr das geklippt habt, das können wir eben auf Twitter posten
Dass das irgendwie etwas
verbuckt ist gerade
verbuckt
Also, Logshipper crashed, okay
Da waren wir jetzt erst mal, Source, Cube CTL
Oh ne, haben wir keine Bash Completion, ist ein Upt, Upt
Ja, Upt, oh man, wir können hier nicht, wir können hier Bash
Wir können hier nichts installieren
Ne, ist schon installiert, oder?
Oh, achso, ups
Ah, Easy hat funktioniert, okay, Cube CTL
Wir haben doch keine Bash Completion geladen
Wartet mal, Source, wo liegt das ETC Bash Completion D, Bash D, oder irgendwas
Ne, moment, Bash Completion D ist es nicht, das sind die, einfach Bash Completion, Sourcen, ich glaube, ich habe das
Das habe ich, glaube ich, noch nie, noch nie voneinand gemacht, bringt das jetzt was, Cube CTL
Cube CTL, get
Pots, Minus A, nice, Funs
Okay, wir haben Autocomplete, Leute, wir haben, wir haben eigentlich schon gewonnen, solange wir Cube CTL Autocomplete haben, eigentlich ist, die Sache ist gelaufen, easy
Ich, ich call's jetzt einfach schon mal, easy
Easy, easy, easy
Easy, easy
Okay
Ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung, was eigentlich kaputt ist, also, lasst mal gucken, so, der hier ist kaputt
Logshipper, also, gucken wir uns mal an, Cube CTL
Get
Pot
Logshipper, Minus O, Jammel, gucken wir uns das mal an, ja
Gucken wir uns mal an, also, was ist, was macht der Logshipper denn, der Logshipper benutzt sein Image, Logshipper V3
Commands, Userbin, Python, Logshipper, ja gut, das ist schon mal
Wahrscheinlich nicht das Problem, dann, Cube CTL, Logs
Logshipper, Moment, brauchen wir keinen Pot, Logshipper
Es, also, das kann auch keiner lesen, was, Exception when calling Core V1 RP read names
Will der auf die Kubernetes RP zugreifen, der Logshipper
Das sieht ein bisschen so aus, auf die
Also, auf den, den, den, eigentlichen Kubernetes Cluster RP, RP Endpunkt
Pondsetters, Cache, blablabla
Hier, Response Body
Ja, der will auf die Kubernetes RP zugreifen, warum möchte ein Logshipper auf die Kubernetes, ne, gut, was auch immer, das ist ja nicht das Problem
RP Version, Failure, Message, Pots
Is forbidden, User, System
Oh, da hab ich keinen Bock, entweder ist es ein Problem mit dem Service Account
Das ist, oder, nee, ich weiß es, ich weiß, die haben, die haben, die haben, ich kann ja nicht mal mehr reden, Alter
Die haben Network Policies, wahrscheinlich, drinnen, okay
Cube CTL, die wollen, die wollen hier richtig hardcore jubeln, get network
Ich dachte eigentlich, man schreibt das groß, get network
Ja, Network Policies, übrigens, nur so als, als kleiner
Kubernetes-Tipp, wenn ihr keinen Bock habt, alles im Detail hinzuschreiben und einfach nur einen Überblick wollt, macht immer Minus A hinten dran, Minus A und Minus Groß A
Ist für, für alle Namespaces zum Listen, meint ihr, ah, shit, okay, es ist schon mal nicht das, was ich gedacht hab
Vielleicht auf die falsche RP wegen Deployment, Pots, Replica, das kann alles sein, ja, ja, ja, ja, du hast recht
Wir müssen uns mal Environment-Variablen angucken für diesen Pot
Habe ich doch hier schon, YAML
Env, kriegt der irgendwelche Environment-Variablen? Ich hasse das Kubernetes-YAML so zu lesen, ey
Environment, nee, nix, oder?
Irgendwie Mount oder so, hat der auch nicht? Oh, doch
Secret Service Account, okay, ist deutsch, aha, guck dir mal hier, guck dir mal hier
Mount Path Service Account, Name, Kubernetes-AP-Access
Also, der, der, also, nicht der Service Account heißt so, sondern
der Mount, der dann im, im Pot irgendwie als
irgendwie Volume, muss ich sagen, glaube ich, Volume, ne?
Ja, genau, hier, das wird gemountet in dem Pot mit Filemode 420
Wie?
Als Config-Map wird das gemountet, okay
E, gut, daran müssen wir aber wahrscheinlich nix machen, das sieht auch okay aus
Welcher Service Account ist es denn hier überhaupt, ja?
Service Account
Log-Ship-ASR
Okay, jetzt weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht weiter, wartet mal, kubectl, wir lassen uns mal alle Service Accounts anzeigen
Gibt's das Ding da?
Log-Ship-ASR, okay, Get Service Account, Log-Shipper
So, das hier sind die, die Definitionen vom Service Account
So, also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, unser Problem hat überhaupt nichts mit dem Logger zu tun, der Logger ist vollkommen egal
Den Logger habe ich noch nicht mal reingeguckt
Der Log-Shipper will an die Kubernetes-AP und crasht, weil er nicht an die Kubernetes-AP kommt
Das Ding läuft unter irgendeinem Service Account und jetzt halt die Frage, also Network-Policies haben sie nicht
Jetzt halt die Frage, haben die irgendwelche anderen
User, wie heißt dieser Kram nochmal?
Roll-Bindings heißt es, glaube ich
Das ist eines der Parts von Kubernetes, den ich echt, das ist so der Endgegner
Das geht mir immer voll auf den Sack, wenn damit irgendwas ist, okay, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, also nach was
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Kubernetes-Service-Accounts
Ich glaube es heißt Roll-Binding, glaube ich
Erbugg, genau, genau
Ja
Mach ein Describe, das ist eine gute Idee, Leute, übrigens, wenn ihr wollt, ihr dürft backseaten, so viel ihr wollt in diesen Streams
Get Describe Log-Shipper, jetzt muss ich wieder Pot machen
Log-Shipper
What the fuck?
Pot Sandbox Changed
Das habe ich legit noch nirgendswo gelesen bisher
Was ist das?
Moment, machen wir hier ein eigenes Fenster auf
Sandbox Changed
Limits
Nee, da kommt der Fehler nicht her
Pepega Stackoverflow
Das ist der Fehler, wenn, den habe ich noch nie gesehen
Pressure, was?
Nodes, das ist doch praktisch was, also ich bin, keine Ahnung, was das, was das ist
Also, nee, nee, der Stream ist noch da, oder?
Chatge
Chatge, hallo, hallo, Chatge, Chatge
Vodafone
Vodafone, oh, Vodafone hat Frames gedroppt
Vodafone ist wieder in dem Element, Alter
So ein Schrott-Provider, Mann
Okay
Ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung genau, woran das liegt
Aber ich zippe, also, weil das Ding ist, dass, das will eindeutig zu Kubernetes API zum
Zum
Cluster-API-Endpunkt, und er darf nicht
So, und man kann das einschränken, aber das ist echt, das ist echt wirklich der Kubernetes-Endgegner, ey
Service-Account-Role-Bindings und Cluster-Role und sowas, ah, was haben wir denn hier, Moment, Moment, Moment, Cluster-Role, Cluster-Role klingt gut
kubectl get, oder, ja, komm, Cluster, Cluster-Role
Minus A, wow, ja, ist ja gut, Mann
Grab minus I, Lock-Shipper
Oh, guck mal
Lock-Shipper
Cluster-Role, get Cluster-Role
Lock-Shipper, naja, super, da weiß man jetzt natürlich Bescheid, komm, edit, edit, edit
Ist direkt, einfach zugegangen gerade
Leute, ich fürchte, das Ding hat gerade den Abgang gemacht, den AWS
Ich glaub, das hat gerade den Abgang gemacht
Oder nicht?
Doch, das hat gerade den Abgang gemacht
Ja, dead, Leute
Es ist dead
Wir müssen noch mal von vorne anfangen
Check-Solution, fuck, ja, wir hätten Check-Solution machen können
Vielleicht hätte es jetzt einfach funktioniert
Wobei, ich meine, Leute, wir haben schon die Bestzeit für Kubernetes-Stells
Ich weiß nicht, bei Check-Solution können wir nicht mal ausprobieren, ich habe ja schon reloadet
Na toll
Wie war das mit kubectl? Das müssen wir jetzt gleich am Anfang machen, das hier
kubectl und dann bash-completion-sourcen, gell?
Guck mal, macht ziemlich, ziemlich nice
Coggers-Loading
Es ist, AWS ist gerade nicht, nicht, nicht so schnell
Aber ich verstehe es schon
Aber ich verstehe es schon, ich meine, das ist alles kostenlos und
Performance kostet der Cloud immer Geld, deswegen ist doch alles, ist doch alles in Ordnung, ich finde es toll, dass es den Service hier gibt
So, open
Okay, sudo minus i
kubectl, jetzt machen wir das gleich mal richtig, bash und jetzt source etc
etc bash
Completion, kubectl get pods minus a, okay, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben? kubectl get
Cluster-Roles, Cluster
Roles oder Role-Bindings, das ist, das ist echt ganz, ganz eklig hier
Und dann ist das Ding, was mit Log-Shipper-Cluster, Cluster-Role
Nee, Quatsch, und jetzt habe ich gesagt, und jetzt habe ich gesagt, wir editieren das direkt, okay
Ah, ich glaube, ich weiß, was passiert ist, ich glaube, ich habe STRG-W gedrückt, um das Wort zu löschen, dann ist das Browser-Fenster zugegangen
Aber das erklärt nicht, warum es nicht wieder aufgegangen ist, so und jetzt, jetzt hören meine
Kubernetes-Skills aus dem Kopf echt auf
Kubernetes-Cluster-Role
RP-Access
Ja, okay, Rules, RP-Group-Resources, Namespaces, Pods, Logs, Verbs
Was auch immer, ja genau, genau
Role and Cluster-Role
Define Permissions
Define Permissions Cluster, Define, ja, ja, ja, ja, okay, das ist ja soweit, soweit klar
Resources, Pods
Ja, Moment, wir wollen nicht
Wir wollen ja an die Kubernetes-RP selbst
Indicates the Core-RP-Group, meine Güte, das ist so ultra kompliziert immer gemacht
Also, was ich hier schon mal, was ich hier schon mal verdächtig finde, dass die hier Get, Watch und List drin haben und hier steht nur List
Aber das muss nicht wirklich viel heißen, so
Und hier, nein, okay, ne, da, hier haben sie nur Get und List
Update, Moment, was gibt's denn da eigentlich alles?
Im Log, im Log steht drin, dass er nicht auf die RP kommt, weil er Forbidden ist
Das weiß ich hier, oh, guck mal, es gibt hier sehr viele Verbs, die machen wir jetzt einfach mal alle rein, ja
Okay, was gibt es denn alles für Verbs?
Steht das hier irgendwo?
Was sind Verbs überhaupt, man?
Also Verben, ja, aber in die Form, ach, in der Form von Get-Requests oder sowas, hm?
Verbs
Also, das habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen, ich kann es dir zeigen, warte mal, guck mal hier in den Logs
Alter, what, zum, wie, ei, what?
Logs
Log, Logshipper
So, da erzählt er nur, dass dieser User, dieser User Forbidden ist
And I cannot get resource pods
Alter, was ist denn heute los, ey?
List of Kubernetes Verbs, okay, nice
Let's go
Weil stand das nicht, da gibt's doch, da gibt's doch bestimmt irgendeine ordentliche Liste, oder?
Delete
Ja, komm, scheiß drauf, zack
Der kriegt jetzt einfach alles, Edit
Verbs, egal
What the fuck, warum bricht der, warum bricht der das Edit immer ab, was ist das für ein Scheiß, man?
Ich raste aus
Ist ja schlimm, okay, Paste, okay
Okay, Escape, X, okay, Role Edited, nice
Wir haben die Role geeditet
Und
Okay, der geht immer noch nicht, das kann aber sein, dass der neu gestartet werden muss
Und, geht das jetzt? Es geht, oder?
Ich würde sagen, es tut, ja, das war's, easy
Ich bin mir zwar nicht hundertprozentig sicher, was ich gemacht habe, außer alle möglichen Access erlaubt, überall hin, aber okay
Nice, okay, wir haben es gefixt, top
Ich weiß zwar nicht genau, was es jetzt gewesen ist, aber wir haben einfach möglichst viele Rechte erlaubt und, und, nice, okay, war's auch immer
Leute, Kubernetes-Experte am Start, Senior Kubernetes-Fivehead-Experte am Start hier
Lauter Fehlermeldung wäre die offensichtliche Lösung die Zuordnung des Pods zu der richtigen Gruppe, meine, ja, keine Ahnung, ich hab
Also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum das jetzt geht
Wir können mal, wir können mal
Clues gucken
Okay, als Root sollen wir uns die
Ah, wir sollen den Pod describen, okay, Chat, ihr hattet recht
Ich habe den Pod nicht, den nicht described, ich habe, glaube ich, mit, ich habe erst Logs geguckt und dann
YAML-Definition geguckt, aber kommt, kommt aufs gleiche raus
Okay, also das haben wir sowas, sowas in der Richtung aber auch gemacht, next
You can view
Log-Shipper-Pod-Configuration-Describe-Command to see the service, ja, das haben wir auch rausgekriegt, ich glaube aber um fünf Ecken irgendwie, weil, nee, das haben wir in der Log-Meldung gesehen, in der Log-Meldung stand das mit Service-Account drinne
Once you find, look role-binding
Cluster-Role-Service-Account is attached
Get Cluster-Role, das haben wir gemacht
Und dann sollen wir was machen, edit
Okay, edit Cluster-Role, das haben wir auch gemacht, ach hier, guck mal, hier erklärt er auch was
Vim-Editor
You can use control
Ja, da hatte ich wahrscheinlich auch Probleme mit
Und danach muss man den Log-Shipper restarten, das mussten wir nicht machen, der ging einfach von sich aus
Wahrscheinlich haben wir ein gutes Timing erwischt, dass der grad wieder am Crashen war und sich neu gestartet hat
Oh Leute, das reicht, ich mach keins mehr heute, das ist genug, genug Kubaniten
Wir haben jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit
Wir können noch mal
Kurz checken, ob es irgendwas interessantes auf YouTube zu gucken gibt
Ich muss grad mal gucken
Ja, war grad irgendwas auf meinem Handy zu sehen, Sekunde, oh ja
Ja
Okay
Ja, was auf Clips umstellen, was habt ihr denn geklippt?
Huge Fake-E-Mail-Adresse-Leak
So, Clips
Das hier oben muss man abhaken, warum das überhaupt da ist, verstehe ich nicht
Okay, eine Million IQ, Kubanitis-Senpai, solves Setzer aufs CTF in less than a minute
Ja, solves vor allem, ja
Richtig, richtig, komplett gesolvt habe ich das
Ich hatte heute auch ein sehr schönes Kubanitis-Problem, und zwar hatte ich Pots, die im Terminating-State feststecken
Weil sie einem Node zugewiesen waren, den es nicht mehr gab, okay
Kann man das nicht irgendwie clean-upen, wüsste ich aber aus dem Kopf auch nicht
Man kann auch bei Kubanitis irgendwie so Stale-Resources irgendwie aufräumen, aber aus dem Kopf hätte ich auch keine Ahnung
Lasst uns doch mal kurz auf YouTube gucken, ob es noch irgendwas Spannendes gibt
Für die letzte halbe Stunde, weil noch eine weitere Challenge fange ich heute nicht an, das kriege ich geistig heute nicht mehr auf die Reihe
Ich hätte echt mal, gibt es, wisst ihr, eine Sache, die es echt zu wenig aktuell auf YouTube gibt
Leider, leider, ich finde das sollte nie aufhören, sind irgendwelche
El-Risitas
mit
Untertiteln
Besser, besser, super
Ey, du
Einfach der Beste
Das ist einfach der Beste, ey
Ich könnte mir das jeden Tag einmal angucken, das komplette Video
Das Original
Das Original, ihr wollt grad sagen, das Original geht ewig, das geht glaube ich eine Viertelstunde oder so
Wo er erzählt, wo er irgendwie seine Nudelfannen ins Meer geschmissen hat und sowas
Beste Mini-PC für Fernseher, was ist das? Und anhand von was?
Also eine Sache, die in Deutschland halt nicht funktioniert, aber die international eine Zeit lang auch sehr beliebt war
Sind diese Hitler-Reacts-Videos
Wo sie diese Szene aus der Untergang nehmen und da gibt es ja auch alles Mögliche, Hitler uses Docker oder
Crashs Kubernetes Cluster und alle möglichen Dinger, das ist halt auf Deutsch nicht lustig
Wir verstehen halt, was die sagen so und wir wissen da auch historisch ein bisschen besser Bescheid, aber das ist international
sehr beliebt so als YouTube-Clip
Wenn Postgres dann, Postgres ist Pog, oh nee, das ist mir zu high IQ jetzt
Ich glaube, ja, ja, glaube ich auch, El Resida ist für Spanier wahrscheinlich auch nicht lustig, ja, gehe ich auch von aus, ja, denke ich, denke ich auch
Wobei ich, wobei ich gehört habe
Dass der Kerl so einen krassen Dialekt hat, dass den auch Spanier nicht richtig verstehen
Wir haben auf der Arbeit in Spanien
Also externer eingekaufte Spanier
Wenn ich das nächste Mal in einem Call bin, muss ich ihn fragen, ob er El Residas kennt
Der ist auch so ungefähr meinem Alter, würde ich sagen, also der sollte sich so mit Internet-Memes auch auskennen und dann frage ich ihn mal
Ob El Residas als Spanier, ob das lustig ist, wenn man das
Wie mit den Untertiteln, ja
Die Story, die er erzählt, eigentlich ist die Story total belanglos und doof, ne, aber mit seinem Rumgelache ist es halt geil
Also das Original El Residas Videos, da erzählt er, dass er in irgendeinem Restaurant am Strand gejobbt hat
Und ihm der Koch erzählt hat, er soll die dreckigen Pfannen sauber machen, ins Meer hängen, also ins Meer hängen, um sauber zu werden
Und da hat er halt die Pfannen ins Meer gehängt und dann kommt er halt am anderen Tag morgens, glaube ich, wieder und
Es war halt Flut und die Pfannen sind weggespült gewesen, so
Das ist halt die ganze Essenz aus dem, eigentlich aus dem original El Residas Video, aber man kann es sich trotzdem immer wieder geben
So, was haben wir denn hier, was können wir uns jetzt mal angucken?
Was ist der, wow, Wonka ist, alter, das ist so laut
Super demotivierte Software-Entwickler, ein Beispiel, Chatge, wer von euch Software-Entwickler und ist super demotiviert?
Also ich muss sagen, seitdem ich meinen Job gewechselt habe, bin ich zumindest aktuell
Es kann ja immer mal ein bisschen schranken, aber aktuell bin ich nicht demotiviert, du
Also haben wir zumindest einen demotivierten Software-Entwickler
Du bist kein, dann lassen wir das mal mit Software-Entwickler weg, seid ihr demotiviert, ja?
Habt ihr, habt ihr innerlich schon gekündigt oder nicht, die demotivierten?
Pulumi, ich mag, ich mag Pulumi, ganz ehrlich, ich, mir ist es lieber als Terraform, leider sind diese ganzen Iac-Tools irgendwie alle, weiß nicht
Nicht so geil, ja?
Ach, du hast sogar schon gekündigt, na dann
Ich habe mit meinem Vater telefoniert
Und er meinte, ich habe, ihr müsst, ich habe mich ja schon erzählt, ich habe mit dem in meiner Weise nicht allzu viel zu tun
Und wir sind, wir sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt so
So die letzten Jahre über hatten wir jetzt auch nicht sonderlich viel Kontakt, hat auch alles seine Gründe, aber ja, zumindest
Ich habe heute
Ich habe mit meinem Vater telefoniert und er hat gemeint so, oh er ist so stolz auf mich so, wie es so karrieremäßig läuft und sowas
Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, okay, allzu gut scheint er mich ja nicht zu kennen, wenn er ernsthaft denkt, ich mache Karriere
Als wäre ich der krasse Karriere-Grinder, man, ich mache, wenn einer keinen Bock auf Karriere-Grind hat
Bin ich das, ja
Ich bin so faul
Was Karriere und sowas angeht, Schritt 1, er muss Abo bei dir abschließen, ja, genau
Okay, ich weiß, wie er es meint, ja, ich weiß, wie er es meint, ich meine, es ist ja, man muss ja schon sagen, es ist
Alles recht gut gelaufen, die letzten Jahre über, ja, ich habe eine Arbeit, wo ich ganz gut verdiene
Ich mache nebenbei ein bisschen YouTube und Twitch, wo man noch ein bisschen was rumkommt, also es ist ja nicht schlecht oder so
Aber es ist nicht so, als würde ich den krassen Karriere-Grind machen, da bin ich echt nicht der Typ für
Was, was haben wir denn zum Ankommen?
Super demotivierte Software-Entwickler, warum sehen wir hier gerade so, ist das ein Schloss? Nee, was ist das, ist das ein
Schwimmbad?
Ich weiß nicht, was das hier ist, ist das eine Skipiste oder irgendwas für Segelflugzeuge?
Was haben wir denn sonst noch? Alter, nicht so laut, man, was ist denn das?
Einfach Zeitverschwendung, wie Linux insgeheim die Welt kontrolliert, ja, das hört an
Reale Irrsinn, bewachtes Klo in Köln
Ja, mit Klos am Bahnhof oder falls, weiß nicht, ob das am Bahnhof ist, da habe ich ja schon öfters mal die Story erzählt
Vom Hanauer Hauptbahnhof und dem Klo, was erst Rebooten musste
Impossible-Doom-Challenge
Okay, komm, komm, wir gucken uns jetzt an, warum Software-Entwickler demotiviert sind, 10 Minuten, 10 Minuten Video laber ich locker, 20 Minuten dazu, das heißt, das kriegen wir gerade so durch
Max, hast du mal mit ROS, mit, was, mit ROS? Ich habe das mal mit AirTOS gemacht, aber nicht mit ROS
Was ist ROS überhaupt?
Oder, oder ROS, oder ist es ROS, oder, was ist, guck einfach das Postgres-Video, ich mache es mal auf
Aber, simples, ich will mir jetzt kein HighIQ-Postgres-Zeug angucken
Ich will mir jetzt kein HighIQ-Postgres-Zeug angucken
Diese Middleware für Roboter, okay, keine Ahnung, nein, aber ich bin nie angeguckt
So, zeige ich mal her, was hat er denn hier zu er... Oh, nee, Moment, ist das der Typ, der durch den Wald läuft?
Ach, das ist der Typ, der durch den Wald läuft, das haben wir doch das letzte Mal schon geguckt, war das...
Zetke, ich kann mich nicht mehr richtig daran erinnern, das war doch gar nicht schlecht, das letzte Video, was wir geschaut haben, oder?
Außer, dass es irgendwie ein bisschen verstörend war, dass er im Wald die ganze Zeit auf uns zugekommen ist
Ich glaube, das war gar nicht so übel, deswegen kriege ich das auch noch empfohlen, und vom Titel her passt es ja auch
Moment, warte mal, aus, so, was?
Ja, was nicht immer Software-Entwickler übrigens so ist, was auch daran liegt, dass ein hoher Teil des Tages irgendwelche sinnlosen Meetings sind
oder irgendeinen anderen Scheiß, ja
Also, ich finde es immer geil, wenn die dann rechnen, so nach dem Motto
Ah, das Projekt, das braucht so und so viel PT, und da können wir einen Mitarbeiter dafür abstellen, was sie aber alle nicht einrechnen ist
dass du nur 50 Prozent deiner Zeit überhaupt arbeiten kannst, weil der Rest mit irgendwelchen Meetings voll ist, und das ist nicht übertrieben
50 Prozent ist durchaus realistisch, ich weiß nicht, wie sieht es bei euch aus? Also, ich habe... Pass mal auf, Leute, machen wir jetzt mal, wo habe ich mein Handy hier?
Gestern, gestern, also
Gestern, und dann sage ich euch heute, okay
Gestern, Kalender, also, Chat, passt mal auf
Gestern
Okay, gestern, also, geht los, und ich mache die Musik wieder an, wobei dafür brauchen wir, dafür brauchen wir eindeutig
Okay
Hast du auch genau dazu?
Also, gestern ging es los
9.30 Uhr bis 11.00 Uhr
Ist ein bisschen zu laut, ist es vielleicht?
Okay, also, ging los, gestern
9.30 Uhr bis 11.00 Uhr
Sprint Review, ja, gestern waren wir super, hyper agile
Massive agile sind wir gewesen, wir haben den ganzen Tag quasi
Diagonal skaliert
Hyperscaled haben wir, diagonal hyperscaled den ganzen Tag, also, 9.30 bis 11.00 Uhr Sprint Review
Dann nebenbei, nebenbei
9.30 bis 9.45 Uhr Daily Scrum, also, ihr merkt vielleicht, dass Sprint Review und Daily Scrum sich überschnitten hat, aber okay
Dann Team Daily, 10.00 bis 10.15 Uhr
Dann 11.00 Uhr bis 12.30 Uhr
Sprint Retrospektive 1, dann
Das kann ich euch so nicht vorlesen
Ich sag aber, ich sag mal nur, 11.00 Uhr, das ist auch parallel jetzt, 11.45 bis 12.30 Uhr
Blockchain, Blockchain Operation
Mehr kann ich euch nicht vorlesen, dann geht es weiter
14.00 Uhr bis 15.00 Uhr
Sprint Retrospektive 2
Und
Ach nee, sorry Leute, das wurde abgesagt, das wurde abgesagt, die ist cancelled, Sprint Retrospektive 2
Dafür geht es weiter
um 14.30 Uhr
bis 16.30 Uhr
Sprintplanung für den nächsten Sprint
War aber super agil, oder?
Also im Prinzip habe ich angefangen
von
9.30 Uhr
bis
Ja, eigentlich bis 16.00 Uhr, 16.30 Uhr, aber mit 16.00 Uhr bin ich schon abgehauen
Also von 9.30 Uhr bis 16.30 Uhr mehr oder weniger durchgängig gemietet
Allerdings stimmt das nicht ganz, weil es war ja immerhin von, sagen wir mal, 12.30 Uhr bis 14.00 Uhr
15 bis 12.30 bis 14.30 Uhr waren keine Meetings, in der Zeit habe ich was gegessen und wahrscheinlich mal kurz irgendwas anderes gemacht, also
sagen wir mal, eineinhalb Stunden hätte ich theoretisch was arbeiten können
Wenn man da reinkommt, aber im Prinzip war, sagen wir mal, 70 Prozent des Tages war Mieten
Okay, es wird jetzt nicht unbedingt besser
Heute
Geht los mit was, was ich echt gut finde
Heute um 9.00 Uhr ging es wieder los, 9.00 Uhr bis 9.15 Uhr
gab es
Neuigkeiten aus unserem IT-Führungskreis
Finde ich mal ganz gut, dass das quasi
auch an die Leute verteilt wird alles
Das gab es, also 9.00 Uhr bis 9.15 Uhr
Dann geht es allerdings gleich weiter
9.30 bis 9.45 Uhr Daily Scrum
Danach gibt es 10.30 bis 11.00 Uhr Weekly Ketchup Call, das ist auch so eine geile Formulierung
Weekly Ketchup Call
Also ich meine nicht Tomatensauce, sondern aufholen, Ketchup Call, dann gibt es
Gruppen, wöchentliches Gruppen-Meeting
Dann gibt es wöchentliches Team-Meeting und dann gibt es noch mal 15 bis 16.00 Uhr
Austausch Synchro-Fix
Projekt mit Projektnummer
So, heißt im Endeffekt
Ich habe von, sagen wir mal 16, sagen wir mal ich würde 8 Stunden am Tag arbeiten, aber es sind
Arbeitszeiten ein bisschen weniger, aber gehen wir mal einfach von 8 Stunden aus, sagen wir mal von 16 Stunden an zwei Tagen
Konnte ich vielleicht drei arbeiten
Nice, oder?
Extremly Pog und dafür kriege ich Geld, aber die wollen es so, das ist auch okay, ist auch ihr Recht das so zu wollen, dann mache ich das auch so
Richtig Agile
Massive, wie gesagt, wir haben den ganzen Tag Hyperscaled in alle Dimensionen
Wie lange geht der Sprint? Eine Woche, zwei Wochen, drei Wochen, vier Wochen, nein
Der geht, in der Regel geht er zwei Wochen bei dem Projekt
Und wie viele der Meetings hättest du gebraucht?
Also unser Team, unser Team Daily finde ich immer ganz gut, den Rest hätte ich eigentlich nicht gebraucht
Ne, ne, ne, ne, du hast hier, du hast hier was übersehen
Naja
Das ist nicht zwangsläufig schlecht
Wenn das alles dazu passt, ja
Hier kann ich auch
Ich mache das, ich mache das manchmal auch ganz gerne, dass ich an dem Tag tatsächlich nach Frankfurt auf die Arbeit fahre
Weil, dann weiß ich jetzt schon
Wenn die Meetings rum sind, kann ich einfach reinfahren
Agile ist der, das kenne ich, das kenne ich
Das könnte sogar einer, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es einer der originalen
Ja doch, ist er, die kenne ich, die Präsentation, die ist gut
Das ist einer der originalen
Agile Manifest-Dudes
Frustriert dich das nicht, du überspielst das ja immer, wenn die wollen, macht sich aber
Naja
Also, sonderlich geil finde ich es ehrlich gesagt
Nicht, so viel zu mieten
Aber, ganz im Ernst
Ich finde es auch nicht so schlimm, wie sich das vielleicht anhört
Wenn ich mich da ein bisschen drüber lustig mache
Weil, es ist, es ist, es ist tatsächlich
Ich sehe das genauso, wie ich das sage
Die wollen das so haben
Die bezahlen echt nicht wenig Geld dafür
Und wenn die, wenn die in einen Technik
Tja, IT-Technik
Typ einstellen wollen
Der kann das so machen
Der kaum Technik macht
Ist das okay
Also, die Sachen, die mich erfüllen
Sind ja meistens, eh
Irgendwelche privaten Basteleien und Projekte
Oder Sachen, die wir hier im stream machen
Wo es mich wirklich auch interessiert
Das muss mich nicht unbedingt den ganzen Tag
Auf der Arbeit interessieren, was ich da mache
Und ich setz mich, also ohne Mist
Ich setze mich auch sechs, sieben Stunden am Tag
In ein Meeting
Wenn mich da Leute einladen und meinen
Und das kommt bei mir auf der Arbeit tatsächlich auch relativ selten vor.
Es soll sich nur keiner beschweren, dass andere Sachen nicht funktionieren.
Ich denke mir das ja nicht aus.
Wenn ich es mir aussuchen könnte, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich etwas weniger mieten.
Das habe ich ja auch sogar im Vorstellungsgespräch gesagt.
Dass ich das nicht gut finde, wie das auf der aktuellen Arbeit läuft.
Und mich mir das anders wünschen würde.
Natürlich hat man dann gesagt, bei uns ist das viel besser.
Wobei sie haben nicht gesagt, bei uns ist das viel besser.
Sie haben gesagt, natürlich gibt es bei uns auch Meetings.
Aber wir versuchen die dann immer zu beenden, wenn der Zweck des Meetings erfüllt ist.
Das stimmt schon. Die meisten Meetings gehen manchmal ein bisschen kürzer,
aber es sind halt trotzdem so viele.
Es gibt sicherlich noch viel, viel mehr.
Ich gehe auch auf viele nicht hin.
Also ich habe ganz viele Termine im Kalender drin stehen, wo ich gar nicht weiß, was das ist.
Beziehungsweise was sie da eigentlich machen.
Da gehe ich dann auch nicht hin.
Also wenn es danach geht, hätte ich ja quasi den ganzen...
Also ich könnte von Terminen her, wenn ich keinen Bock hätte was zu machen,
ich könnte echt den ganzen Tag mieten.
Und ich habe auch teilweise Tage, da habe ich vier oder fünf, und das ist jetzt echt kein Witz,
vier oder fünf Paralleltermine.
Aber das meiste irgendwelche Infosachen, wo ich nicht weiß, was sie wollen und ich hingehe.
Storymappings, jetzt wird es aber richtig hyperskaliert agil.
So, also wir wollten uns eigentlich...
Eigentlich wollte ich mir noch das Video angucken.
Jetzt habe ich euch, jetzt habe ich euch mein Meeting-Tagebuch vorgelesen.
Ne, wir gucken uns Chat...
Ich lasse das auf, wir gucken uns das Video nicht an.
Ich muss in sieben Minuten ins Bett.
Wenn ich jetzt die bestbezahlten Ausbildungen...
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das skippen wir jetzt schnell durch.
Okay, zeig mal her.
Okay.
Platz 10.
Für was?
Okay, Immobilienkaufmann.
Gefolgt, was?
Keine, was stand da?
Keine Immobilienmakler.
Ach, keine Ausbildung.
Wie zum Teufel kann was, was keine Ausbildung gibt, zu den bestbezahlten Ausbildungen gehören?
Ach ne, das kann man werden danach wahrscheinlich.
Okay, was, was kommt als nächstes?
Ich habe es verpasst.
Alter, YouTube.
Berufen denkt man jetzt nicht direkt an ein kettes Gehalt.
Aber die Ausbildungsvergütung kann sich echt sehen lassen.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ach, hier haben wir es noch, guck.
Maurer. Okay, nice.
Gut, die brauchen halt wie verrückt Leute, ne?
Kaufleute für Versicherung und Finanzen.
So, als nächstes haben wir.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Die Tabs sind doof.
Was ist das? 7?
Was zum?
Ach, das Video ist so dumm geschnitten, das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Da findet man nicht die wichtigen Infos.
Man muss das Video tatsächlich gucken.
Oh ja, der hat mir jetzt noch gefehlt.
Microsoft zu xExpert talks about Windows 10.
Okay, top.
Ich brauche jetzt, Leute, ich brauche jetzt, bevor ich ins Bett gehe, noch eine Runde.
El Risitas.
Ahi.
Es ist alt, das Video, okay, aber.
Windows 10.
Der Microsoft-Bub.
Heißt das Mira, die Touch-Over-Flasche von Windows 8?
Das war der Beste, Alter.
Okay, Windows 10.
Risitas.
Okay.
Das ist so eine Windows-Helplicht anders.
Ey, du.
Ja.
Okay.
Ich habe schon bessere Varianten gesehen.
Ey.
Ey, ohne Scheiß.
Forced-Updates haben sich eigentlich gar nicht allzu schlecht rausgestellt.
Wenigstens läuft jetzt kaum noch die Oma mit einem fünf Jahre alten, outdateden Windows 10 rum.
Naja.
Da habe ich schon.
Oh, oh, was ist das?
Kennen wir das schon?
Linux-Guru talks about Linux-Desktop.
Okay, das ist so lange her, da kann ich mich noch gar nicht mehr dran erinnern.
How many years of feelings?
50 Jahre.
Too strong.
Ja.
Si?
Oh, Shell.
Das sagt 13.
Aber Shell ist mittlerweile auch ein Source.
Ist klar, ja.
Das ist die Ausrede, die bei jedem kommt, wenn er Torrent-Laufen hat.
Warum hast du Torrent-Laufen?
Ja, ich muss Linux-Distribution runterladen, lalala.
Okay.
System D?
Ich wusste, dass System D kommt, lalala.
Von wann ist das Video?
Ja, okay, sieben Jahre.
Ja, da war System D und innen noch Riesendiskussionen, ja.
Und du?
Mittlerweile ist System D da und funzt eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich wusste, dass es ein Torrent-Laufen gibt, aber es ist nur ein Torrent-Laufen.
Jetzt stimmt ja nichts, aber ...
Oh je, ohne Scheiß.
Vor sieben Jahren haben sie sich über Wayland lustig gemacht.
Funktioniert heute vieles immer noch nicht richtig.
Zum Beispiel noch vor einem ordentlich.
Naja, gut, okay.
Die Linux-Variante war deutlich besser als die Windows ...
... als der Windows Resitas.
Alles klar.
Gut, so, das muss jetzt zum Schluss noch mal sein.
Chetke, ich sehe, ihr seid schon alle im Bett.
Da gehe ich jetzt auch ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns die Tage, Leute.
Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.